two of the greatest thespians of all
time are back together in the new Martin
Scorsese film the Irishman Robert De
Niro and Al Pacino but today it's not a
team-up it's an all-out battle royale to
see who has had the most impressive
career and all week the trash talk
between these two has been hot see they
both really want to win this and I'm
excited to be here because I even
dressed like I'm in the Irishmen Pacino
De Niro neither one's Irish oh well
here's how I'll determine my winner
round number one box office round two
tomato meter round three most iconic
then we'll do a wild-card round after
which you the audience will have the
final say so without further ado let's
kick off what could be the most hotly
debated episode in the history of this
show it's the dude from Mad Dog & Glory
versus a guy in G Li let's get it on
[Music]
[Applause]
both of these legendary actors have been
in the talkies for decades but don't
worry we adjusted the box-office for
inflation so the money's fair but what's
not denier has been in so many more
movies than Pacino Bobby D has made 77
films that we have data for Al just 37
so predictably De Niro's combined total
movie receipts are stacked higher than
Pacino's so this should be an easy round
win for Robert right what kind of a show
you guys putting on here today no not so
fast
despite trailing De Niro by 40
theatrically released films Pacino is
competitive in both domestic and
worldwide box-office totals Robert can
claim the hefty 5.2 billion dollars in
the States and nine point nine billion
dollars worldwide al currently stands at
four point two billion dollars domestic
and seven point five billion overall and
Pacino's average film gross is actually
well above his counterpart over 200
million dollars per flick while DeNiro
is just a hundred and thirty million
dollars as you can imagine they both
have had their share of hits Robert De
Niro's highest grossing
film of all time well it just happened
Joker it crossed a billion bucks ask for
Al Pacino
he made this little movie a long time
ago maybe you've heard of it uh The
Godfather
be that 1.5 billion dollars and that
friends will buy a lot of new bedsheets
the horse joke I hope they put that clip
in he's got the better average and is it
more Godfather movies so Al Pacino is
gonna win round number one round two
tomato meter Robert and Al I feel so bad
calling them that it's like if they were
here I could even look them in the eye I
just get nervous and stand in the corner
like Blair Witch e chicken [ __ ] Bob and
a slice as two giants of cinema have
made a ton of films that are super high
the tomato meter however their average
is not so much only one fella can claim
a fresh average that's Al Pacino at
sixty one point nine percent Robert De
Niro gets close at fifty six point four
percent but again De Niro's made like 40
more movies so there's bound to be some
stinkers in there hold your nose as we
run through the duds De Niro's the gang
that couldn't shoot straight is zero
percent Wow no one liked it but to be
fair it only has like 5 critic reviews
godsend is it 4 percent as is the bridge
of st. louise ray if those films don't
ring a bell I know what will Jack and
Jill Pacino
makes an extended appearance in that all
time pile of junk and it says tomato
meter low pointed three percent who is
the three percent that likes Jack and
Jill who walked out of that movie like I
had a really good time you live on
Pacific
okay let's get that stink office with
this list of the gentleman's most
celebrated cinematic accomplishments
Robert DeNiro checks in with a pair of
98% fresh classics like taxi driver and
Brazil
Al Pacino also has a 98% on his resume
that being The Godfather okay again who
was the 2% that did not like the
Godfather it's got to be the same folk
that like Jack and Jill right it's not
personal Sonny it's strictly business if
you combine all their movies and do a
top 10 according to the tomato meter De
Niro can boast eight of those films
including a Bronx Tale which he directed
Pacino has three and if that math
doesn't check out for you it's because
they were both in The Godfather 2 which
is a pretty sweet 97% more movies more
in the top 10 and much less Jack and
Jill that means the win and round number
2 goes to mr. DeNiro so Debra round 3
most iconic this is where even me Marc
Julius Ellis will admit my competitive
nature gets the best of me I mean who's
more iconic their Pacino and De Niro who
doesn't do the Travis Bickle line you
talking to me who's never won a court
case it immediately bellowed hooah
so let's take a look at the most iconic
roles to see who maybe has a slight edge
Al Pacino kicks off with Michael
Corleone we know him we love him he's
into some seedy stuff just what I
thought I was out okay then you have
Tony Montana awesome in a CD stuff
Serpico by the way
Al Pacino got so into character while
making Serpico he tried to make a
citizen's arrest on someone I can't even
commandeer a Ford Focus from my mom
that's joke let's toss in Sonny from Dog
Day Afternoon Tony D'Amato and any given
Sunday and his oscar-winning turn as
Frank and Scent of a Woman is that kind
of a sneaky creepy title sensible I know
the guy's blind but hi I'm Frank I go
around smelling women just it's a little
off-putting to me anyway
intelligence of which you have none so
what iconic portrayals from Team DeNiro
can man
the Pacino squad how about Vito Corleone
from Godfather to Sir Travis Bickel Jake
LaMotta from Raging Bull Jimmy Conway
from Goodfellas Al Capone so the only
way to break this most iconic deadlock
is to focus on the one film that sees
them square off against each other the
movie that stars both Robert and Al if
you're at home and you said Righteous
Kill then I want you to pause this video
out side take a walk around the block
then come on back inside when you're
ready to be an adult
we'll wait the movie is heat the Michael
Mann classic is it I guess it's a
classic features a fiery its subdued
DeNiro crook facing off a boisterous
overt Pacino it's these two guys doing
what they do best and who wins in the
end
Pacino I think right there was a long
movie both those are all-time legends
but this round goes to the cop who
helped bring down the toughest robbers
in Southern California since those
surfing ex-presidents mr. Al Pacino I
worked hard for this wildcard round
versatility we both know these fellows
can go the mobster route like in the
Irishman which again is where this shirt
is from I hope you're enjoying the
French tuck that doesn't help they can
take care of that kind of thing they can
paint houses kill you and bury your body
in Jersey De Niro's played a mobster 11
times and that's not even counting when
he was just a criminal in flicks like
rhoda noir Jackie Brown Pacino has been
up to no good in nine movies so while
these may be their most well known roles
what else you got if you think Al is
good as a mobster wait until you see him
play Satan he's everything you'd want as
John Milton and if you're playing the
devil we want a loud pompous
over-the-top speech and boy did we get
it you know what scares me John I leave
the case she gets better and then I hate
it for Pacino is also magnificent as
Sonny and Dog Day Afternoon Ricky Roma
in Glengarry Glen Ross he tried really
hard in Jack and Jill again that's an
all-time bad movie but watching Pacino
give it everything he has is truly
inspiring and you feel a little sorry
for him then we come to mr. De Niro
Pacino has done a few comedies De Niro
has crafted an entire second career out
of them let's go all the way back to mid
nite run which earned him one of his
Oscar nominations and add in the analyze
this films and the Meet the Parents is
like most comedy franchises they went
back to the well a little too often but
it was Robert De Niro that sold those
films as much as any of the more
traditional funny people like Billy
Crystal or Ben Stiller and I can say
this with all confidence his comedies
are better than Jack and Jill Robert De
Niro's worst comedy is still way better
than Jack and Jill I've seen gum on
sidewalks that I'd rather chew then
watch that movie again it's outside of
the world of comedy where DeNiro seals
the win in this round he played the
legendary monster and Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein then he can go play nice
sweet retiree been in the intern and the
links he will go to for a role include
massive weight gains 60 pounds for
Raging Bull and another 30 pounds to
play Al Capone and the untouchables but
come on really how hard is it to put on
weight you have a few extra pancakes in
the morning taking extra milkshake into
the shower with you we all do that but
he also lost 29 pounds to play Travis
Bickle and he got in like scary shredded
shape to play max Cady and Cape Fear
Martin Scorsese great filmmaker and
personal trainer his ace client Robert
DeNiro gets the win oh you got a gift my
friend so here we are at the end of this
game all tied up this is one you want
your most clutch player to shine through
sadly you just got me and between Al
Pacino Robert De Niro my pick for the
best is fun sidebar time simpletons like
me like to invent a rivalry for these
two fellas but the reality is they're
good buddies who have a tremendous
amount of respect for each other however
there have been a few roles over the
years that could have gone to either sue
Robert De Niro was considered for the
role of Michael Corleone II that role
went to Al Pacino we're seeing out to
bow out of the gang that couldn't shoot
straight so Robert stepped into that
role Pacino is considered for taxi
driver before De Niro land of the part
and Robert De Niro turned down the role
of coach D'Amato in any given Sunday
under Al Pacino you see kids in life the
inches we need are all around us
that's what I'm going with Robert DeNiro
for the wind why because it's Wednesday
and that's how I felt when I woke up
this morning this is such a crock of
[ __ ] this way better to be king for a
night then schmuck for a lifetime coulda
gone either way
but it's not lost on me that he is the
lead in the Irishman and he still
carries a film in a way that you have
ever been able to do he can also play
comedies multiple ways and Terex say his
range feels a little broader as we get
towards our senior years but that's just
my opinion now it's your turn
comment below and tell us who the better
all-time great is and your peepers is it
Pacino is it DeNiro or does Joe Pesci
win in a raid in Bauer thanks for
watching I'm Mark Ellis and yes I was
talking to you no one else here must
have been talking to you so horrible
Travis Bickle and that's how I'm walking
out bags
I'll practice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]